>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
HEADING FOR MINNEAPOLIS RIGHT
NOW WHERE YOU WILL HOST A
CAMPAIGN RALLY LATER THIS
EVENING.
AGAIN, YOU WILL SEE THAT RADEON
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
OUR LATEST FOX NEWS POLL
INDICATES DESPITE THE
IMPEACHMENT RUMBLINGS, THE
PRESIDENT IS HOLDING ALIGNED
WITH REPUBLICANS HEADING IN TO
2020.
17% OF REPUBLICANS SAY THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOMEONE ELSE
AT THE TOP OF THE TICKET BUT
NEXT YEAR, 77% OF G.O.P. VOTERS
WANT TO KEEP THE PRESIDENT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RIGHT THERE.
CORRESPONDENT KRISTIN FISHER IS
IN MINNEAPOLIS TONIGHT WITH A
PREVIEW OF TONIGHT'S EVENT.
THEY CROWD IT LOOKS LIKE.
>> GOOD EVENING.
THIS IS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FIRST
CAMPAIGN RALLY SINCE DEMOCRATS
WANTED THEIR FORMAL IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY AND HE'S DOING IT IN THE
CITY OF MINNEAPOLIS.
THIS IS DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSWOMAN
ILHAN OMAR'S DISTRICT.
THE CITY'S DEMOCRATIC MAYOR IS
TRYING TO GET THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
TO SAY ABOUT HAT AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS IN SECURITY
COSTS, SECURITY FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS RALLY AND THERE ARE
BIG PROTEST PLANS OUTSIDE THIS
ARENA TONIGHT.
IN FACT, SOME OF THEM HAVE
ALREADY STARTED.
MANY BELIEVE THIS IS A STATE
TRUNK AND WIN IN 2020.
HE LOST IT IN 2016 BY LESS THAN
TWO POINTS.
THIS TIME THEY ARE INVESTING A
TON OF MONEY IN CAMPAIGN POWER
IN MINNESOTA.
THEY PUT 20 STAFFERS ON THE
GROUND WITH PLANS FOR NEARLY 100
BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
>> I THINK WE CAN WIN.
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE A
REPUBLICAN ONE.
OVER 80,000 PEOPLE REQUESTED
TICKETS.
IT'LL BE TOTALLY SOLD OUT.
THEY HAVE A LINE NOW THAT IS
MANY BLOCKS LONG.
>> HERE IS A LIEN THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOW REFERRING
TO.
THOUSANDS ARE INSIDE THE CENTER
WAITING FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT
HE WILL BE INTRODUCED BY THE
VICE PRESIDENT RIGHT BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT COMES ON.
IT'S LIKELY PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
MENTION TONIGHT ALONG WITH THE
MAYOR AND CONGRESSWOMAN
ILHAN OMAR BUT THE BIG THING TO
WATCH TONIGHT IS HOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP DEFENDS HIMSELF
AGAINST HIS IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
THREATS.
HE'S MADE THIS CASE OVER AND
OVER ON TWITTER BUT THIS IS THE
VERY FIRST TIME WE WILL GET TO